[Music]
elon musk
has called off the deal with twitter oh
no no
what happened to free speech he was our
only hope i know guess i gotta go back
to parlor
i'm on truth social
send me the truth wait is that the trump
one yeah i send my truth what's your
what was the truth you sent today no i
don't know what the [ __ ] dude is that
even out yet i think it is
not what's truth social like it's just
where a bunch of conservatives are all
there sharing the same information yeah
they're just all jacking off over was it
was it was it trump that started that
one yeah he made his own right yeah yeah
okay he's the top user yeah
he's the only one using it he's the
power user private twitter
private
it's their little form yeah so so why
did this deal get called off uh there's
a lot of uh guess work going on right
now but he called it off according to a
filing on friday with the sec right so
the u.s securities exchange commission
there was a letter to twitter's chief
legal officer
um that says twitter has not complied
with its contractual obligations which
is going to be musk's angle
for nearly two months the company's
failed to provide much with the
information about fake or spam accounts
which is his big case like he's saying
he thinks that like three out of every
10 users are bots wow so they fluff up
the
user base to be like yo look this is why
we should be evaluated we look at all
the users and then he's like i want a
[ __ ] good deal so clean up the bots
and then i'll buy it and musk is saying
like hey i think the we should be
valuing this way less what i'm offering
because it's billions right yeah like 44
billion or something
it should be 2 billion the news sent
twitter stuck tumbling 5
and after i was trading um the stock has
obviously fallen for a while now like
most stocks have anyway so people like
to [ __ ] on me about luna but everything
[ __ ] fell so [ __ ] you
uh everything's dripping [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
you actually uh but also uh yeah it
makes me sad too
uh no but there's also no recovery for
us yeah there's no no it's over for us
so but um
but hey at least i have this
gold watch
um it's mostly plastic but there's some
gold i think on the dial
if you know i think it's like i think
there's like 30 dollars of gold in there
so 30 whole dollars
damn that's one of my lunas
me too me too
and [ __ ] you me too
um
so the yeah the um twitter clothes at
70 cents uh a share like recently
uh
like on the day of the announcement he's
going to buy it but then like today it
closed at 36 dollars
so it's really taking a tumble
and the crazy thing was when he was
offering 44 billion or whatever when the
price was 51 or whatever um
anybody who had owned twitter a single
share i think if that deal went through
would have got like like 15 a share yeah
in profit pretty sick so that's why it
became one of those things where it's
like if the twitter board were to refuse
elon's deal even though he was praying
paying a premium over the price
it's like they would be uh in essence
denying their shareholders from a profit
which is why they quote unquote
shouldn't or couldn't have done that but
obviously
[ __ ] is complicated kind of a win-win
for him though right because on the one
hand if he
if he wins this and they give him the
numbers that back up his claim that
they're fake users then the price drops
and he gets a deal on it if he loses
then he gets out of this crazy [ __ ]
expensive deal and everyone looks at him
like oh wow you know you're standing up
for x y and z yeah it's interesting
because he wasn't even he wasn't even
like the only person in the deal so he
had a bunch of financiers as well oh you
there were other people buying it with
them yeah yeah oh so so cause initially
it was gonna be him and then he got some
people to jump on with him because was
michael jordan one of them michael
jordan was not one oh okay so but that's
a sick guess yeah okay if you want to
keep guessing why did you think michael
jordan was one of them you have 14 more
guesses michael jack because what about
michael j fox no because michael jordan
always does cool [ __ ] he does cool [ __ ]
he's a sick [ __ ] he's got his fingers on
the pulse that guy yep uh was joe rogan
one of them because he likes free speech
without kevin hart no joe organ doesn't
put his money where his mouth is oh
that's true without the rock yeah the
rock doesn't like joe rogan the rock
likes to sell shitty tequila yeah
shots fired
i also realized none of them were
billionaires so they probably couldn't
afford it yeah gwen is paltrow she's a
billionaire goop could have bought it
yeah maybe no but she actually likes
suppressed speech so i think i don't
think she would be
if jay-z rihanna tiger woods
together
yeah they're all billionaires they are
tiger woods the billionaire yeah you
just hit it what do you do
you play
you play golfbidder it's more it's more
his endorsements like the endorsements
and stuff like that the tiger woods line
most athletes and celebrities all make
their money off products and other
impacts oh dude
presents the pga tour that was a sick
game yeah dude
lebron
lebron is also a billionaire but he's
like still super active in league and
that's amazing obviously tiger still
plays but you get it well you think
lavone is good at basketball because i
think he's not even close to being the
goat i think it's staff step all day
well i love steph too so i'm i'm not
going to talk
did they give us a list of who's
his financier team yeah no um
but here's the thing right so a lot of
people on the right were feeling like
elon was going to save them because
a lot of people on the right have felt
banned by twitter
however a lot of people on the left at
least not the progressive left but the
liberal left have felt like they have
been made by twitter as well because
they question a lot of narratives that
they receive through corporatist america
so they're saying like hey we get banned
and then the right gets banned
but then like the progressive left is
like twitter's tight
that's what's weird to me is like people
don't know that even within the
democrats there's like they're all split
up too yeah they don't all look look at
bernie dude he literally got ripped off
by the dnc
it's a fact it's actually been admitted
to in court it's crazy people don't even
know that and they but then you know and
no one's getting punished no when you
bring up rigged elections everyone just
does the sneering [ __ ] but it's like no
literally bernie got ripped off yeah and
he would have probably been the best
competitor against trump but then that
during the hillary nah they snubbed them
for hillary
and he had to [ __ ] but you know what
though like for him like having to
endorse her and playing that game that's
when i was like man you just like one of
them yeah yeah son of a [ __ ] he lays
down too quick you know that uh andrew
uh uh yang he's doing his own party
are you used to liking i used to love
you you don't like his socialist ass
anymore uh no it's not about that it's
it's about how he embraces media
narratives like hardcore for some
[ __ ] reason but then he questions the
unit party which i like but then he like
hardcore embraces like uniparty
narratives so i'm like it's weird huh
it's weird yeah he i just can't get
right with the guy can't make up his own
[ __ ] line
well i i just can't tell what he's
trying to say for like for what he
thinks and what he's saying because he
thinks it's okay to say is he playing
the game like where's his yeah what's he
thinking but he had jesse ventura on his
podcast recently which is very
interesting
really andrew yang yeah what i got to
see that jessie vitter is the dude i
love jesse ventura dude i'm from
minnesota
i tell you what what's going on with all
these different parties
there's so much going on people really
realize i [ __ ] love that guy i wonder
if he's still on russia today
what is that still a channel dude russia
today had so many so he did you watch
russia today no but
it's rt but but they had larry [ __ ]
um what's his name larry um elder dave
no no no
the interview guy the [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah yeah larry king larry king
they they're all just like larry king on
[ __ ] russia today they had jesse
ventura had his own show
like there was hell americans that were
hired to do it because their narrative
was your media isn't really that free
we'll [ __ ] give you guys a show and
you can say whatever the [ __ ] look at
ukraine bro no no no nom chomsky just
came out and said you can't even hear in
america the united states where
everyone's supposed to get free
information you can't even hear the
russian side of the story just their
side of the story who gives a [ __ ] if
you agree with it you can't even hear it
because the media blacks it out yeah so
noam chomsky who is like
like
frankly socialist of the year one of the
godfathers of the progressive left
he's saying he's sounding the alarm
about that and everyone's going like
you probably love russia bro
so that's the problem right now it's
like it doesn't matter what you say they
will associate you with being like some
enemy provocateur
when you're not even doing that you're
actually just asking questions yeah like
dude i love julian assange this is what
woke me up to the whole thing julian
assange is my [ __ ] hero he's a
traitor he's a traitor he's a russian
trader and so is snowden he's a russian
trader they say that to this day if he
tweets anything they're like where are
you in russia right now you're in moscow
are you sucking on putin's dick while
you're [ __ ] writing this thing and
it's like what did he do he literally
told us the surveillance state is
betraying us they're spying on you
watching you your every move and that's
weird and sus that's all he said yeah
and people are going like oh my god like
you're probably a russian
stooge you're helping russia and all
this [ __ ] it's wild it is wild it is
wild to say hey you know the nsa is
actually listening to everybody
illegally
on their phones confirmed through many
court cases and it goes is this american
and everyone's like you [ __ ] russian
[ __ ] get out of here it's wild
dude is it is it illegal what they're
doing isn't it yeah it's impatient
actually isn't it the whole patriot
acting that's a loophole for them that
works that way well
the patriarch is illegal
it should be it's not constitutional in
my opinion well not constitutional legal
or different things in america well
abortion is not constitutional thank god
we had to get out somehow
you